un temps des changes entre élus locaux
et commerçants des clayes-sous-bois pour
ce peuvent mener pendant la corrida
les discussions autour des difficultés
actuelles ont été rassurantes
le fait que la mairie nous soutiennent
dans nos démarches et nous aident pour
la réouverture des terrasses qui vont
démarrer le 19 axes majeurs du dialogue
la mesure d' aide d'urgence aux
commerces de proximité financé par le
département
nous avons entendu que 40 commerces sur
les 150 des clayes-sous-bois allez
pouvoir bénéficier de cette aide alors
donc on n'a pas encore le nom de toutes
les sociétés et tous les commerces qui
vont pouvoir en bénéficier
mais c'est une réelle aide surtout dans
cette période une aide pouvant aller
jusqu'à dix mille euros selon la nature
de l'activité et la durée d'interdiction
d'accueillir du public
ils sont tous exprimés bien entendu une
grande satisfaction de disposer de ces
aides dans des temps aussi difficile que
ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui parce que comme
ils l'ont et comme ils n'ont précisé
pour certains il ne faisait que que 10 à
20 % de leur chiffre d'affaires j'ai pu
voir que il était tout à fait à
l'enquete à fait prêt à repartir de
l'avant et que l'aide que le département
leur avait apporté était ce socle sur
lequel ils pouvaient alors pas forcément
que matériellement mais aussi
psychologiquement rebond rebondir il
avait le sentiment de ne pas être seul
comme inquiétude partagée entre élus et
commerçants les enjeux de la reprise de
l'activité avec la peur d'une pénurie de
main d'oeuvre au moment de la
réouverture